- We have an incredible show today, y'all.
Joining us is one of the funniest,
most groundbreaking comedians
in the history of American
television and film.
She's won a Tony, a Grammy, six Emmys,
and seven Golden Globes,
'cause why the hell not?
(Kelly laughs)
Winning all of them.
She was awarded the
Presidential Medal of Freedom,
as well as the Mark Twain
prize for American Humor.
Tonight, on NBC, you can
actually watch her tribute.
It's called "Carol Burnett, 90
Years of Laughter and Love."
It's incredible.
(audience applauding)
And today happens to be her 90th birthday.
Everybody, give it up for
the iconic Carol Burnett!
(audience cheers and claps)
(carefree music)
(audience continues to cheer and clap)
(audience continues cheering and clapping)
Hello.
- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Keep that going!
- Stop...
- Oh my gosh.
- Thank you.
- We're so excited you're here.
- [Carol] Oh, I'm so excited to be here.
- I feel like my show just
made it, that you're on it.
(Carol and Kelly laugh)
(audience cheers)
- We're very excited.
Today is a very special day.
Obviously, happy birthday.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers again)
- It was my birthday two days ago.
- Your birthday is the 24th.
- We're both Tauruses.
24th, yeah.
- I'm the 26th.
- 26th
- You and also Shirley
McClain and Barbara Streisand.
- Don't you think I know it, girl? Yes.
I was very excited as a kid.
- And your birthday, yeah.
There's a lot of Tauruses killing it.
Just saying. We're pretty cool.
We're both from Texas as well.
- [Carol] That's right, yes.
- Yes, was it San Antonio?
- San Antonio.
- Yeah.
- Do you miss anything?
Because you were young when
you moved to Hollywood, right?
- It was back in the covered wagon days.
- (laughs) The Oregon Trail.
- I went to Davy Crockett Grammar School.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- In San Antonio, yeah.
- [Kelly] I like San Antonio.
- He was alive then.
- (laughing) No, he was not.
(Carol and Kelly laugh)
- I miss the queso.
I miss chips and queso from Texas.
That's my favorite thing.
- The best Mexican food, ever.
- The Tex-Mex, yes.
- Yeah.
- I know.
- That's the first food I remember eating.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Cu it-
- Enchiladas.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- My mouth just watered.
- And then I had my milk.
(Kelly laughs)
- Then I had my bottle.
- Yeah. A little bottle of milk, yes.
- So everybody, Carol has given
the world so many good times
and so many laughs over the years that we,
as a selfish gift, more
to ourselves than her,
want to look back and relive
a few of those moments.
So, we have compiled a
collection of memories.
This is Carol's scrapbook.
A look at 90 years entertaining the world.
(audience cheers)
(cheerful music)
Okay, so let's start at the beginning.
Here we go.
So, Carol was doing characters
from a very young age.
In fact, is it true that a
neighbor once got upset with you
because he heard...
- Oh! (Carol laughs)
It sounded like a real radio station?
- Well, I lived with my grandmother.
She raised me.
- Yeah.
- And we had this one room apartment.
- And so,
it butted up against another building,
another apartment building.
So, I would sit on the couch
and I would open the window
and I would pretend to be a radio show.
- Yeah.
- You know, I was about
10 or 11 or whatever.
And I would say, "And
now ladies and gentlemen,
you're going to hear from a young lady
who's going to sing acapella,
without any orchestra accompaniment."
And then I would sing and
pretend to be this, right?
And finally somebody from
the building next door said,
"Turn that damned thing off."
(Kelly and the audience laugh)
I was thrilled! (Kelly laughs louder)
I mean, they believed it.
They really thought it was a radio show.
- You were that good.
(Carol and Kelly laugh)
You're like, "Thank you."
Okay, let's move on to your
late teens and twenties.
So, here we go.
You started acting in college,
in Los Angeles, right?
- [Carol] Right. UCLA
- [Kelly] How did you
end up going to New York?
What made the move?
When did you make the move?
- Well, I was in a musical
comedy workshop at UCLA
and we did a scene.
I did a scene from "Annie
Get Your Gun" as a final.
They were gonna grade us on
it, but there was an audience.
And afterwards this gentleman
and his wife came up to me,
and they said, "We liked you very much,"
and, "What do you wanna
do with your life?"
And I said, "Well, someday
I wanna go to New York,
and be on the stage, and
be in musical comedy,
- Yeah.
like Mary Martin and Ethel Merman."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The gentleman said, "Well,
why aren't you there now?"
And I said, "Well, you know."
We were...
- Costs money.
- [Carol] Yeah. And we were poor.
- Yeah.
- And I said, "But someday
I hope to save up enough."
And he said, "I'll lend you the money."
And so he did.
- A complete stranger?
- Yep. And I thought,
"What, is he kidding?"
And his wife said, "No, he'll..."
And he lent me
one thousand dollars.
And he said, "Pay it back when
you can, within five years.
Stipulations:
Don't ever reveal my name.
You must use the money
to go to New York on.
And if you are successful,
you must promise to help
other people out too."
(audience applauds)
- What a beautiful lesson,
right off the bat.
- So I did.
I took the money. I went to
New York and I got lucky.
(Carol chuckles)
- I think talent had
something to do with it, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- I paid him back.
- That's incredible.
- Yep.
- So you were... I love this.
I'm gonna switch from this beautiful thing
to you were fired.
- Oh.
- From an early job you had
as an usher, at a theater
on Hollywood Boulevard.
- [Carol] Right.
- So what happened? How did you get fired?
- Well, what happened...
It was 65 cents an hour
that I was getting,
and I was an usher.
It was my part-time job
while it was summer,
and I was still a UCLA student.
And we had to wear these funny outfits.
I had epaulets, and harem
pants, and a fez hat and all.
And I was standing in
front of aisle two's door
this one night.
And back then they would
just show the movie
over and over and over.
So, people would come in
in the middle of the movie.
Yeah, that's what they did back then.
It was stupid.
- What?
- Yeah.
And then they would sit
there, and then they'd wait,
and then they'd watch it and
it would start over again.
And they'd say, "Oh, this
is where we came in."
And then they'd leave, you know?
So anyway,
- [Kelly] Wow.
- we were showing an
Alfred Hitchcock movie.
- Yeah.
- Now there's a thriller.
And it was "Strangers on a Train."
It was the last five minutes
and it was gonna start again.
This couple came in
and wanted to be seated
in the last five minutes
of an Alfred Hitchcock Movie!
- Spoil alert.
- [Carol] I mean, you know....
So I said, "Oh, please
no. It'll ruin it for you.
Go get popcorn. Go to the bathroom.
But, it'll start all over,
and you should see it from the beginning."
Well, the manager came up and
said, "What's going on here?"
And this woman said, "She
won't let us sit down."
And I said, "But, Mr. Batten..."
That was his name.
"Mr. Batten, please? It'll..."
He said, "Burnett."
I said, "Yes?"
He went, "keech."
Literally, he went "keech,"
and he ripped off my
epaulets. (Kelly laughs)
And I was fired on the spot.
- Oh my god!
- Well, nice, nice ending to this story.
Several years later when they said,
"Where do you want your star
on Hollywood Boulevard?"
(audience groans)
- Oh my God.
If that's not a joke- (Kelly laughs)
(audience claps and cheers)
Oh my god.
You got 'em in the end.
- I did. (Carol and Kelly laugh)
- So, let's turn the page
to Carol's first big success on TV.
Here we go.
So, you were on "The Garry Moore Show,"
- Yes.
- in New York,
which was hugely popular at the time.
So, what do you remember
about that experience?
- Oh, well, first of all
there wasn't a nicer human being
that I had ever worked
for than Gary Moore.
- [Kelly] That doesn't always happen.
- No.
- Yeah.
- There were times when we
would be reading the script
for that week,
and Durward Kirby was also.
He was the second banana on the show.
- Yeah.
- That's what we were.
They call them second bananas.
And if Garry had a punchline,
or a joke or something,
he'd look at it, he'd say, "You know what?
Give this to Carol, or
give this to Durward.
They can say it funnier than I can."
That's the kind of man he was.
- He was confident.
- Absolutely
- Not insecure in his talent.
- Not at all.
- It's people that are
insecure, I feel like,
that get in their own way.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Moving on to 1967,
which is when Carol started
her own iconic variety show,
"The Carol Burnett Show."
It's incredible.
I didn't know this,
but you were originally
supposed to be in a sitcom
when you came to Hollywood?
So, how did you end up doing
a variety sketch show instead?
- Well, I had a contract that
was very unusual that said,
if I wanted to do a musical
comedy variety show,
all I had to do was push a button,
and CBS would have to put it on the air
for 30 one hour shows,
whether they wanted to or not.
- What a great contract.
- I know. (audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- So I thought...
I pushed the button, and I called,
and they said "What?"
I said, "I want to do the variety show."
And they said they'd
forgotten about the contract.
- You didn't. (Kelly laughs)
- I didn't.
And I said, "You know where..."
And he said, "You know, Carol,
comedy variety is a man's game."
- Can't hear that enough.
- [Carol] Yeah, it's a man's game.
It's Dean Martin.
It's Sid Caesar.
It's Jackie Gleason, Milton Burr.
Literally, he said,
"It's not for you gals."
- Wow!
- So I said, "Well,
this gal wants to.
- Makes you wanna do it more.
- Totally.
They had a sitcom.
He said, "Oh, we've got this
great sitcom you could do,
called "Here's Agnes."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- And you'll be able to turn
everyone on, yeah. (laughs)
- Here's Agnes.
(Kelly and audience laugh,
then Carol joins in)
I said, "I don't wanna
be Agnes every week."
- Got this great role.
- No thank you.
I want to have a rep company.
I wanna have music.
I want to have dancers.
I want to have guest stars.
- Yeah.
- I want to have all kinds...
They had to put us on the air.
- You know what?
I don't know if I've
ever heard of a contract
really working in an
artist's favor before.
(everyone laughs)
That might be the first time, yeah.
So your show really pushed
the envelope though.
Did the network ever
try to change something?
They had to have, right?
Something that you wanted to do?
Did they...
- They left us alone, pretty much.
- What?
- Yeah. There was only one time
that the sensors had
something to say to us.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Harvey was talking to
me as an interviewer,
and I'm a nudist behind a...
- [Kelly] I know this one, yeah.
- behind a fence, you know?
And so, I'm bare shouldered,
and I have bare legs and
high top sneakers on.
- And you're spraying for
mosquitoes or something.
- You remember!
And so his line was,
"So, what do you nudists
do for recreation?"
And for my line, I said,
"Well, we have dances
every Saturday night."
And then he said, "How
do you nudists dance?"
And my line was, "Very carefully."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
They thought that was too dirty.
- Oh...
- Yeah, the network thought,
"Oh, you can't say that.
You have to go with something else."
So this is what we came up with:
"We have dances every Saturday night."
"Well, how do you nudists dance?"
"Cheek to cheek."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Which actually, is even better.
- Of course!
And they bought that.
- We have a clip of that,
because I love this one.
- Oh, you do?
- So, let's show it.
(audience on original video laughs)
- [Harvey] Tell me, do you
have any kind of a motto
or sss...
(audience on original video laughs)
- I got the little devil.
(audience continues to laugh)
(tinkling musical run up a glockenspiel)
- [Harvey] I was asking, do
you have any kind of a motto
or slogan?
- Oh, no. But we have a camp song.
- [Harvey] Oh? What's it called?
- On a Clear Day You Can See forever.
(audience on original video laughs)
- [Harvey] Tell me, what
kind of a social life
do you have here?
- Oh, same as anywheres else.
We have movies, parties, dances...
- Dances?
- Uh huh.
- [Harvey] How do nudists dance?
- Cheek to cheek.
(audience on original video laughs)
(studio audience laughs)
- I love it.
I have said this so often on this show,
but comedians are my
favorite actors, generally.
Because, I don't know what it is.
One, you're really witty.
Usually highly intelligent individuals.
But also,
I think comedians, you're
able to go really deep.
You're able to go to the depths
where some people are afraid to go,
because you're willing to
do it for either a joke,
or you're willing to do it...
So that willingness, I think,
makes y'all better actors.
It makes you far more captivating.
- I actually, it sounds
patronizing on my part,
but I think comedians can do drama easier
than a dramatic actor can do comedy.
- No, I... One hundred percent.
- Because of timing.
- Yes.
- You know, that's the important thing.
- And I do think that there's something,
'cuss one of my first jobs was, actually,
waitressing at a comedy club,
and it was interesting
to see them on stage,
and then when all the patrons left, right?
And then you saw that some
of them could be quite dark.
- [Carol] Right.
- But highly intelligent,
very introverted.
And it was like the opposite
of what you saw on stage.
- We would get dark
when we did the family.
- Yeah.
- With Eunice and Mama and Ed?
- Loved....
- Those were...
There were no jokes in that.
- That's interesting.
- It was all character driven.
And one time we were doing
a scene, rehearsing it,
and I don't remember
if it was Harvey or me,
but one of us said, "Just for fun,
let's do it without all the
accents and all the crazy,"
the way we would normally say a line.
- Yeah.
- So we played it totally straight.
- There wasn't one laugh.
- Yeah.
- Not one laugh.
It was so heavy.
But then we put the spin
on it with these accents
and the way we talked
to each other, and all.
- Yes.
- And then it became funny.
It was a great acting..
- It's one of my favorite
things, ever.
Exercise.
- Exercise, yeah.
- Yeah.